to abby listen i will always remember  where i came from i really respect the  show and i respect what the show did for  me for maddie for kalani for kindle for  nia they all act as if i had nothing to  do with the show and oh it was toxic  they were stars they were making money  they were on top of the world you're  just gonna dump me abby actually taught  me a lot i carry a lot of what she  taught me with me we were shooting the  television show and all those kids were  talking about boys jojo was on that  computer she was uploading her own  videos she was hustling back then she's  a household name every store you walk  into it's not going to stop